[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i mean listen to me man you think that
like being the way i
look i was killing it in the 90s
i wasn't because imagine this look at
this body yeah you didn't have this body
right okay you didn't have you know
you're
why you gotta make it like that i don't
do anything i mean that's what i'm
thinking but don't
i don't know but you don't have what you
know what i have i think that you're
wrong
i don't care what you you're not gonna
it's not what i thought i know but
you're not gonna believe this but i
sincerely from the get-go found you to
found you attractive
all right i mean she also grew up around
a lot of koreans
yeah she's like in high school i would
have dated dude no you wouldn't dated
[ __ ]
you
ugly oh yeah i [ __ ] up ton of ugly
guys because i wasn't that cute either
when i first came from the philippines i
had a [ __ ] i wanted
you [ __ ] back then you know what to gum
ratio it was i was a mess who else could
i couldn't have
had of that statement she's like of
course i would have dated you
i dated other ugly guys
can we ask you a question about that
yeah like and i don't mean i'm not
trying to like perv out on you
but when you're dating a guy who's gay
right closeted gay
is it no prob like can he get aroused
by being with a woman yeah so what i
found a little sauce
was that it always had to be face down
okay
and it always he did this thing where he
was like he would be like get like
in other words put you in that like you
yes he would it was always his preferred
and on top of that like it was never
like even flat prison style
like he would if i was flat on my face
like my body was flat he would straddle
me like a horse
oh like he would like [ __ ] like this
like as if i was just it was it was it
was weird
and that was that was the regular that
was the routine that was just a routine
wow he would do it face to face
eventually right sometimes
um only for like what he had to imagine
with his face when he did face to face
he'd be right
i found it interesting that you know at
22 i was really
a buff athlete i have androgynous
features
i do have kind of like kind of like a
boyish kind of
what physique so i think he was really
into that
i'm definitely confused at this part but
yeah okay she's she has a swimmer's body
yeah this swimmer's body big back
okay yeah all right at 22 especially i
was just
you know jack jack okay
so you're not not not saying that when
i'm making love i'm not like going oh
it's michael phelps
by the way i'm not doing that all right
let's be clear fyi
let's be clear to be clear you're kind
of a woman
a warrior you'll see comics if you walk
into a green room
yeah there are some comics and they
can't help themselves they'll go
when i walk in and then you and then
i've been conditioned to laugh at it but
it hurts
it does it burns really yeah it burns
because you but you have to go that's a
good one
you know i mean like you've seen it 30
million times in your life
of course yeah i just can't he's gonna
get beard and blood i'm gonna get beard
in plants
really stop stop stop stop why don't
you just i'm serious why would you love
like tell me what you're so i understand
what are you planning on doing getting
beard implants which is like a hair
transplant you hear it don't grow here
are you serious yeah that's good i
looked it up how much it is where to go
is it a lot 6500 that's not bad at all
and would be
like everywhere no can i just say this
yeah
just don't tell people that i'm getting
it done i know i'm saying it on this
podcast i understand that but
comics don't listen to this wait does
ching chong really not mean anything
i think means um
um hello maybe can we can we just
address something about it though
it's it's a fun thing to say yeah it's
like it's unfortunate that it has
negative you know racial connotation
because it really
it really feels slows off the tongue it
feels like tell me
tell me you guys have seen there is a
very offensive meme
okay it's it's a mentally handicapped
asian guy
and he's a maestro of an orchestra i
know exactly what you're talking about
and it says
and a one and a three and a ching chong
potato
yeah and it's easily the funniest meme
i've ever seen in my entire yeah right
is it offensive yeah yeah it's just very
funny
very funny but also like it also it
would be nice if it was acceptable to
use
for like you know what i mean like let's
say you were like hey uh
you know my my mom made this dish and i
was like what is it and then you could
be like it's just some ching chong [ __ ]
you know
you know so are you religious
no but i was raised by two pretty devout
catholics oh thank god okay all right
now we can have this discussion okay so
mike
i always raise catholics yeah i mean i
have a south american mother so that's a
that's kind of like
to the 10th power catholic you know like
we get in the car if it's a
drive that's longer than 10 minutes
word good
no it's just because i'm not a catholic
because i wasn't racist christians right
i had just certain ideas about you know
religions yeah i mean and so um for me i
always thought that
there was a complete and utter gap or
difference between
you know modern-day born-again
christianity
yeah and catholicism there is there is
but what that wasn't what you said
earlier he said that catholicism
wasn't a branch of christianity and i
was like no it absolutely
it's the it's the foundation yeah
christianity everybody's
everybody with protestantism of course i
understand that i
understand the fact that he was
screaming about it i wasn't screaming
about it
and i just please don't rewrite history
like the catholics do all right like the
classics
okay yeah so what i'm just saying is is
um because i always found that
um born of the born-again christians
right just
because i've met them obviously can we
admit that just boarding again
i've lived with them before yeah yeah i
mean whereas you know one time i was
living with this redheaded guy which
gave me a weird
but anyway um he i don't know if i told
you this but i left a
hustler magazine out just out in the
living room
and he is a born and green christian and
i came home one day
and he was crying he was crying and he
had the hustle on his hand
and he was crying how dare you
and i go what bro you can look at it
right and he goes no i masturbated to
this
and i sinned and if i would have done it
if this was not in the living room
yeah this is the same [ __ ] that used
to [ __ ] take my sunny delight
and he bought sunday delight and he
would put a measuring
line so that i wouldn't drink it santino
no it wasn't
it was it sounds like a santino yeah
right yeah and so what i would do is i
would fill it with water every time i
drink it
right so eventually it was just water
right you know so um
you were giving him half the sugar right
so he he
you mean like moved out because i left a
hustler magazine
that prompted him to move out right so
he was born again he was like devout
like he did
you know i mean the harvest was he uh
did he overdose was he like an addict or
usually these people get into that i got
arrested
no no but then i lived with a catholic
guy
right and we would watch porn together
i mean like side-by-side laptops you
know i mean we just jerk off together
he didn't care telling andrew earlier um
because we waited three hours for you to
arrive
and and we would have waited forever i'm
sorry i already apologized i'm sorry you
were the
tomas sir thomas sir thomas
okay and we know um i'll tell you this
this is a this because
this is actually just more wholesome
than the only other time
that i completely forgot i was scheduled
to do a podcast
yeah so this is the second time yeah
today i've said a big tennis match
you know i was out in the sun i got home
showered laying on the couch
literally andrew's like let me know when
you get there and i was like [ __ ]
right and i just panicked yeah got my
kid dressed and i was like yeah you guys
got to watch them and i just jumped in
the car
the last time was in 20
god i want to say this is 2012. holy
[ __ ] but i remember it like it was
yesterday and i had agreed to do the
scar brothers podcast
which is one of the best they're great
they're great guys
and they're like hey will you uh you
know come on
on friday and we'll see you at at noon
and i go yeah okay
i'm jerking off looking at my phone
watching porn like stroking my and it's
just you know the the iphone thing
it's like randy sclar and i'm like and
as soon as i see his name i'm like
[ __ ] so he's like are you close and i
was like to coming
yeah about sexual
sexual oh rick oh we're talking about
sexual or podcasting
i was i mean we could add sex sure okay
no what i'm what i want to know
is who you would you podcast with well
that's what we did
we did we already did that so then who
who's going to replace these are
companions
but yeah that place me sexually okay as
a lover does it have to be i would run
i'm running away from this community
and industry as a whole okay i wouldn't
[ __ ] with a comedian
to make up a guy what he had but if i
had to choose a comedian if i had to
a gun wouldn't necessarily even need to
be in my head but it would absolutely be
jamar neighbors
okay interesting i love him i i find him
so attractive
jamar neighbors you would hammer
that that would be my guy different yeah
no i see a lot of similarities
let's go through them no because i'm
gonna i'll be honest with jamar
neighbors is a shock to me
is it it's just he's muscular so
muscular like he's way more muscular
than i am and he doesn't have to try
it's just there
oh yeah that's a great [ __ ] jack he's
jacked yeah he's also uh much younger
um and then who's your lover now
no comedian thank god but if it had gone
to your head i had to
i chose that's a fair that's a fair play
so hard babe
you have to oh
god i'll choose one probably an open
micro
yeah here yeah i would need an open mic
and also someone who's kind of impressed
you know like
yeah yeah i need that right right
like wow i wanted to come into this
podcast and go oh yeah wow
yeah these two you'll be like you could
do this too one day keep at it come over
here
you know you know me i was on a flight
and some redneck
comes up to me and goes he wanna you
could tell he wanted to talk to me you
know how to bring it up
so he just goes hey man i go what's up
he goes my daughter shh
she loves hello kitty that's all he said
yeah just to spring up you know i mean
conversation yeah
and bc as an ethnic person i know where
he's coming from
that he's trying right he's trying so
for me
the trying in itself
to be fair the guy that created hello
kitty you look
strikingly like that's the problem
that's good
why would i be in the middle seat of a
southwest airlines seat well because
you're just trying to save some money
yeah man yeah yeah not everyone that's
what i see so his assumption is man
that's group
e yeah this guy is group e hello kitty
guys
guys group southwest like the rest of us
yeah yeah
he's a common man you should have said
how did you know it was me
right how'd you know oh right played
along right no wait when he did that
because you at that point can go what
the [ __ ] are you telling me that for
right but what how did you i'm sure i
know like john cho
yeah john cho would have been like hey
man
that's [ __ ] crazy what you just said
right he would have said that
right because i know who joncho is right
my kid loves hello kitty
yeah yeah but i would have been like you
know what i mean what i was like was
like hey man that's cool
yeah i think it's good stuff too you did
yeah
i love it too and he was like i'm just
saying yeah i know that
you know yeah yeah
ain't no right way just the wrong way